[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología
soy valentina torre sánchez y es un
gusto acompañarlos en esta ocasión desde
casa a causa de la pandemia de kobe 19
iniciamos con la controversia que rodea
al medicamento educarlo más un fármaco
que hace poco recibió la aprobación
acelerada de la administración de
medicamentos y alimentos de eeuu como
tratamiento para las primeras fases del
alzhéimer porque podría detener el
deterioro cognitivo en principio es
clave entender que una aprobación
acelerada se genera cuando se da luz
verde a un medicamento para tratar una
enfermedad seria o mortal y el fármaco
puede proveer beneficios terapéuticos
significativos frente a los tratamientos
ya existentes según lo que ha demostrado
ensayos clínicos
sin embargo sobre esa droga y sus
beneficios aún puede haber dudas
si la vía que eligió la idea de obtener
la aprobación acelerada es sabia porque
significa que tienen alguna esperanza
que el fármaco será eficaz se basan en
los biomarcadores que reducen la
proteína
en el cerebro y ahora le queda a la
compañía demostrar que ahora un impacto
clínico positivo en los pacientes en el
futuro
puntualmente en el alzheimer se generan
placas amiloideas depósitos de proteína
beta amiloide en el cerebro y es allí
donde el fármaco actúa fue desarrollado
por la farmacéutica bayer gene se
inyecta una vez al mes y su costo supera
los 50 mil dólares por inyección
de la dukan omar es un medicamento que
entra en el cerebro en pequeñas dosis
rompe las placas amiloideas y ayuda a
eliminar las posiblemente ayuda a
ralentizar la pérdida de memoria es un
fármaco que se puede administrar de
forma segura intravenosa y creo que es
el comienzo de una nueva era en el
tratamiento del alzheimer
y la noticia llegó en medio de un gran
optimismo porque desde 2003 no se
aprobaba un fármaco para esta enfermedad
además se trata del primer medicamento
que está dirigido a lo que se considera
es una parte de la raíz del problema y
no a calmar los síntomas los
medicamentos que hemos tenido hasta la
fecha que se utilizaron hace casi 20
años aumentan las sustancias químicas
del cerebro en pacientes con
enfermedades de alzheimer pero no hacen
nada para abordar los procesos ya sean
test que creemos que están relacionados
como la acumulación de estas proteínas
anormales y este medicamento el educando
map fue diseñado para eliminar la
proteína amiloide del cerebro y creemos
que la acumulación de amiloide comienza
muchos muchos años antes de los síntomas
no obstante también produjo reacciones
cautas pues se realizaron tres estudios
clínicos separados en los que
participaron más de 3.400 personas y los
responsables aseguran que quienes
recibieron el medicamento tuvieron una
reducción significativa de estas placas
que se forman en el cerebro pero una
cosa es que se reduzcan
y otra que los pacientes mejoren su
desempeño cognitivo o se disminuya el
deterioro además los resultados en fase
3 fueron contradictorios uno sugiere que
la dukan omar detiene el deterioro
cognitivo levemente mientras que el otro
no observó ningún beneficio en ese campo
otro punto por analizar es que algunos
expertos indican que aún si el fármaco
logra detener el deterioro sería tan
leve que no alcanzaría a compensar los
riesgos de inflamación y sangrado en el
cerebro observados como efectos
secundarios es por ello que la fedea
pidió al laboratorio violent que realice
un nuevo estudio y sino arrojar
resultados positivos el medicamento
podría perder esta autorización
dejamos este tema y ahora vamos a
argentina que se convertirá en el primer
país de américa latina que realizará
tratamiento de protones para combatir el
cáncer al país ya llegó un ciclotrón que
es un tipo de acelerador de partículas y
otros componentes de transporte de
protones al centro argentino de
protonterapia todo será instalado en un
edificio de casi 8.000 metros cuadrados
que se está construyendo y que podría
atender a unos 2.000 pacientes una vez
que esté en funcionamiento el centro
tendrá dos sectores de tratamiento
clínico uno con protones y el otro con
fotones y contará con un laboratorio de
investigación y desarrollo de
protonterapia donde se llevarán a cabo
actividades de investigación información
finalizamos en hong kong con la más
reciente creación de la empresa hanson
robotics que son los fabricantes de la
famosa robot sofía hablamos de grace
otra humanoide que surgió en medio de la
pandemia de kobe 19 y cuyo principal
objetivo es interactuar con personas
contagiadas y adultos mayores
el equipo
puedo visitar a las personas y alegrar
les el día con estimulación social entre
tenerlas y ayudar a guiar ejercicios
pero también puedo hacer terapia de
conversación
tovar vio lecturas y ayudar a los
proveedores de atención médica a evaluar
su salud y entregar tratamientos
mientras hablamos tomaré tu temperatura
y el pulso con esta cámara térmica en mi
pecho mira tienes 36.6 grados no hay
riesgo de covite además notó que estás
receptivo y consciente eso es bueno
es una apariencia humana facilita la
confianza y facilita un compromiso
natural porque estamos programados para
interacciones cara a cara así somos los
seres humanos y darle una cara es
familiar para la gente reconforta a la
gente y también tiene habilidades
lingüísticas que son reconfortantes
los responsables de grace prevén que la
robot empiece a producirse en masa en
agosto
llegamos hacia el final de este espacio
si quieren repetir este otros programas
pueden visitar nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]